and that is nancy pelosi's mo she
doesn't lose votes on the floor if she
had the vote she would have called for
the vote joining us now with more is
congresswoman elise stefanik and former
senior counsel to president trump
kellyanne conway good to see you both
congresswoman we'll start with you
we see what's happening with the
democratic party uh this started out at
3.5 trillion although if you use joe's
math it wouldn't cost us zero zero pay
your fair share
but
that math doesn't work now it's 1.75
manchin's still saying he's sticking at
1.5 do you see and you're you're
on the floor
the democratic progressive caucus going
along with a mansion cinema style bill
absolutely not democrats are in utter
disarray sean and this is a lame duck
speaker of the house nancy pelosi is a
lame duck and we know that both joe
biden and nancy pelosi and the entire
democratic party is being controlled by
the far left socialist progressives that
you played earlier today the cory bushes
the aocs the premier pramila jayapals
who do not represent everyday working
americans and when it comes to the price
tag of the bill sean they are cooking
the books this is going to cost the
american people over 10 trillion dollars
if you look at it in a 10-year window
they are just expiring these programs
which they have every intention to try
to continue in perpetuity they are
cooking the books to try to hide the
price tag from the american people and
it's not just the fact that it's the
largest tax increase and the largest
spending bill in our nation's history it
is riddled and loaded up with far-left
policies like mass amnesty for illegal
immigrants heat your home tax as we're
heading into what will be the most
expensive winter ever in our nation's
history so this is absolutely a bad deal
for the american people but the
progressives have they're controlling
nancy pelosi right now who is a lame
duck speaker of the house
can you see a scenario kellyanne um
we've both been doing this for a long
time is there a scenario here because
the the margin is so tight in the house
four vote difference that maybe this
this
squad caucus
uh pushes pelosi out
well they may i think her days are
numbered if they were to keep the house
which they won't i think that they're
walking into the kind of shellacking
that president obama claimed he had
suffered
after the 2010 midterms and it's for
much the same reason overreach you know
it's senators mansion and cinema sean
who are more aligned with public
sentiment if you look at the fox news
poll 53 percent of those polls said they
are extremely concerned about inflation
no other issue cracked 50 percent on
that measure
and you have a
democratic president and a pelosi who's
not responding to what economic concerns
are vexing americans in fact another
poll said 58 disapprove of joe biden on
the economy and 60 percent said that
biden's not doing enough on inflation
the answer to inflation is not this out
of control spending that elise just
described the answer to inflation is is
is making sure the supply chain is not
disrupted is making sure that the cost
of everyday items are not exploding and
this is even before we get to
thanksgiving christmas the jewish
holidays where people are spending money
and they're going to blame joe biden for
the expense of those look if joe biden
can't convince liberals in his own party
to spend other people's money how in the
world would he convince global leaders
on the world stage to do any of this
joe biden's presidency sean it is a
man-made disaster they've gone today
they went from disarray to total
dysfunction and i think the progressives
are playing pelosi's game against her
and they're going to prevail they're 96
strong in that caucus and they're
playing the long game here they want us
to reconfigure the federal government's
relationship with each and every one of
us through spending policies and they'll
play the long game here um i think
cinnamon at cinema and mansion should
come over to the republican party call
ronald mcdaniel tonight call donald
trump call whomever you want because we
won't chase you into bathrooms we won't
run millions of dollars at ads against
you in your own state only because you
agree with the majority of americans
that we don't need more taxes and we
don't need more spending
you know congresswoman we have the most
deaths from the pandemic in 2021 the
weakest growth up since the pandemic
with joe biden i mean literally the
slowest growth on record to this point
and a vaccine mandate looming we have
less than a minute we'll give you the
final word
well we have seen that instead of
dealing with issues that are impacting
everyday americans whether it's
inflation the supply chain crisis
democrats are trying to shove through
this multi-trillion dollar package and
when it comes to the vaccine mandates
sean i'm from my home state of new york
i represent new york's north country we
are facing a historic labor shortage and
the vaccine mandate is only exacerbating
this this is what kellyanne is referring
to when this is about remaking
government where government is
controlling your lives that's not what
the american people want democrats are
woefully out of touch and i don't think
nancy pelosi is going to be able to
deliver this over the finish line joe
biden is right that this is going to be
the determinant of his presidency and
it's an utter failure it has been crisis
after crisis
all right congresswoman thank you
kellyanne always great to see you hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else